[Laughter]
[Music]
megan fox just did her best britney
spears impression
and we gotta admit it's pretty on point
it's mind blowing megan stopped by the
kelly clarkson show on thursday
and explained how the pop star helped
her overcome her fear of flying
even if you hit turbulence and you're
like i don't like how this feels
i would throw on certain music that i
just knew
i wasn't gonna die to which was like
for me that was britney spears like the
archives like from when i was young so
like the oops album or like
and i feel like because you're not gonna
cause you're not gonna go out like that
i'm
not a girl
i mean come on that's pretty impressive
people love it and megan she doubled
down on her point
that's not the soundtrack to my dad so
that always made me feel better it's
also just you're not gonna like
meet god on a like a baby and then
you're dead and you're like
you know all the mysteries of the
universe in that moment so for me that
was really helpful
she makes an interesting argument but
let's run that britney moment back
one more time see what i did there one
more time
okay
[Music]
of course the transformers actress knows
all about good music
megan is currently dating machine gun
kelly and she's made cameos in not one
but two of his music videos bloody
valentine
and drunk face
megan recently helped celebrate her
man's 31st birthday with a dinner at la
hot spot delilah
[Applause]
the two shared a sweet kiss before he
blew out his birthday candles
and meg she shared this tribute to mgk
on
instagram writing quote happy birthday
blonde angel baby
i think it's wonderful as for megan's ex
brian austin green whom she shares three
kids with
he's currently dating dancing with the
stars alum sharna burgess
was it an instant connection did you
know right away or were you
a little hesitant no there was
in going to the first date which was
really just coffee right
we were both like okay weird requests
from our business manager but sure
we'll see and then we lost time you know
we sat there for four and a half hours
and we took our time and we really got
to know each other for
who we are on the inside and it built
something really beautiful
but a source tells et meghan isn't fazed
by her ex's new romance
quote she doesn't really care who brian
dates but she has her standard set high
for anyone that meets or is around her
kids
okay now back to megan and machine gun
kelly in
march a source told et that the two are
very in love adding quote
mgk always puts megan first treats her
like a queen
and is super respectful thoughtful and
funny
which are all qualities that she loves
mgk
is head over heels for megan and didn't
think he'd get so lucky to score someone
of her caliber